[Music]
Geneva lies in the southwestern corner
of Switzerland it's the country's
second-largest city Abba iden card
journalist Montes karad is here for the
annual geneva international motor show
mata says everyone who's anyone in the
auto industry always turns out for this
event about seven hundred thousand
people are expected to attend the show
this year and there's a lot to see for
example a Porsche station wagon the
Panamera Tori smell has a big tailgate a
low loading sill and a lot of extra
storage space um Porsches chief designer
says the goal was to develop a sporty
model with a high degree of
functionality on Phonics upon me to the
94 points or none attained this car was
a real surprise for station wagon fans
then there's the new Porsche 911 gt3
which combines superior performance and
lightweight design to provide a unique
driving experience
[Music]
who brings their lips Monta says the gt3
features a 4-liter engine and has an
output of 368 kilowatts a lexus RCF gt3
harnesses just as much horsepower it's
driven by a 5.4 liter v8 engine and will
compete and several racing events this
year here's the fifth generation of the
lexus LS for luxury sedan BLS 500 h
hybrid model is powered by a 3.5 liter
v6 gasoline engine and two electric
motors which together delivered 260
kilowatts of juice volkswagen is also
presenting its elegant new model the RT
on its the successor to the Phaeton the
luxury sedan features frameless windows
a broad low hood and dynamic contours
reminiscent of the classic Gran Turismo
design I'd vhp mother says this is a
really elegant car but those who want a
sporty your model might want to consider
the art line version here's vw's vision
of the future a self-driving car the
manufacturer calls cedric it's an
electric vehicle that's supposed to be
able to get around without a driver but
that goal is still a few years away yes
folks welcome to company CEO says VW
wants to help shape the future of the
car industry that's why it developed
this car and he's convinced that this
concept will work over the medium-term
midler a so-called San Quentin
toyota has come up with some futuristic
ideas as well like the I trill it's
still not clear whether this electric
three passenger car will ever go into
full production that will depend on
whether consumers are willing to
purchase something this unconventional
fun day has been working with hydrogen
propulsion for 20 years now the EFI fuel
cell concept is the fourth generation of
this technology and the successor to the
ix35 fuel cell the new model expands the
cars operating range to 800 kilometers
EFI fuel cells are set to start
appearing in production models next year
some of the models here have been on the
market for decades like the Suzuki Swift
it's been around in one form or another
for 33 years the sixth generation of the
model features a new design including
black a pillars and vertical lights on
the front and back end there's also a
hybrid and a four-wheel-drive version
SIA has rolled out the fifth generation
of its popular he beats a model a total
of five point four million avisas have
been sold around the world the supermini
comes with engines that run on either
regular or diesel fuel a natural gas
engine option may be available later and
everyone's seen smart cars starting
around the city this limited-edition
model is making its debut this year in
Geneva the smart bravo's 42 convertible
edition number two just 100 of them will
be made in all mercedes is presenting a
sleek new design with its eClass
convertible the new version is 13
centimeters longer than its predecessor
and seven centimeters wider
benzene time their board member put to
Ziggy says it offers maximum driving
enjoyment without sacrificing comfort or
space is this is optimal enables the
e-class convertible is four point 83
meters long which makes it bigger than
similar audi or BMW models Monta says
the convertible completes the package of
e-class models that Mercedes has on
offer I get to this leech off you start
playing pen opal is focusing on
crossover designs this year here's their
new crossland X compact SUV it may look
small outside but there's plenty of room
within it's got an attractive overall
design and you can choose the color of
the roof
[Music]
skoda is presenting two variations of
its popular Kodiak model the scout and
sport line silver design details front
and back really make this model stand
out and for off-road adventures the
Scout comes equipped with underbody
protection then there's the elegant and
dynamic sport line which offers a host
of sporty visual enhancements as well as
tinted rear and second seat side windows
and 19-inch alloy wheels with 20-inch
versions as an option this is the 50th
time Japanese automaker Mazda has taken
part in the geneva auto show they're
celebrating with the premiere of the
cx-5 the second generation of their
compact crossover SUV it's longer and
lower than previous models and features
a striking new grille design velocity
montes says he has mixed feelings about
this year's geneva auto show he was
expecting to see more standard
production vehicles that have
alternative propulsion of fuel systems
but 2017 could bring more surprises